ils ont le visage fermé ce matin ses
deux employés du réseau de transport
divia sont excédés ce contrôleur affirme
être régulièrement victimes d'agressions
et ne plus travailler en sécurité on se
rend compte qu'on est beaucoup adressé
menacé et des caillassages des menaces
de mort des violences des bousculades
donc c'est une accumulation de choses
qui font quotidiennement
on va travailler avec la boule au ventre
jeudi soir un tramway et caillassés dans
le quartier du mas iasi nos deux vitres
de la ram sont endommagés le conducteur
légèrement blessé
ce chauffeur de bus n'aurait jamais
imaginé pouvoir devenir un jour la cible
de ce type d'agression
quand on arrive dans une entreprise
toute nouvelle on n'imagine beaucoup de
choses forcément positive et après
effectivement avec les années on
s'appelle on s'aperçoit que ben entre la
théorie et la pratique c'est un peu
compliqué donc on a des capacités
d'adaptation mais quand ça concerne le
thème de la sécurité par contre on est
intransigeant
le soir de l'incident la société divia
décide de suspendre le trafic dans le
quartier pour préserver la sécurité de
ces achats c'est notre métier un de
transporter les personnes du quartier de
desservir ce quartier maintenant de
donner priorité à la sécurité
aujourd'hui l'ensemble de nos salariés
sont mobilisés pour assurer ses services
c'est pas facile ça dure depuis
plusieurs mois nous on est conjointement
auprès d'eux on est solidaires au niveau
de l'entreprise
mais c'est une situation critique saison
critique on n'en a pas connu depuis très
longtemps jusqu'à ce que la situation
s'apaise
la cgt souhaite que la ville de chenôve
ne soit plus desservi après 20 heures
le syndicat déposera prochainement un
préavis de grève